Hello and welcome to the video.
In this video we're going to look at updating Burp Suite Enterprise Edition running on a
Kubernetes deployment. While scanner updates are set by default to update automatically,
Kubernetes deployments do not automatically update the version of Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
However, because all of the data is held within the database rather than the app itself,
you can easily update the installation without affecting any of your configuration settings.
This is done using the latest version of the Helm chart and the Helm upgrade command.
Before you update Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, you should disable scanning. Any queued scans,
that is scans that have been created by the system but have not yet started, will fail if
they attempt to run during the update process. To disable scanning, open the Scan Resources
Settings page and set the Enable Scanning toggle to Off. This prevents Burp Suite Enterprise Edition
from creating any new scans. Disabling scanning does not affect any scans that are currently in progress.
You can safely let these scans run while updating as any scans that have already been started
are not affected by the update process. To update a Kubernetes installation of Burp Suite Enterprise
Edition, you will first need to download the latest version of the Helm chart from our releases page.
As with the first installation, unpack the new chart into a directory of your choice and make a note
of the name. You are now ready to run the Helm upgrade command. This is similar to when we installed
the application but will upgrade the existing deployment instead. First we specify the namespace that our
deployment is in, followed by the deployment name, and lastly the path and name of the latest version of the Helm chart.
After you have run the upgrade command, the application updates immediately. Note that there may be a few
seconds of downtime during the process where the web console is temporarily unavailable. Once the Burp Suite
Enterprise Edition web console is available again, you can re-enable scanning by opening the Scanning
Resources Settings page and setting the Enable Scanning toggle back to On.
!